foreign
[Music]
justice pasenko found that there was
enough evidence in those published
newspaper articles to successfully
establish that those reports were true
now there were a number of allegations
that were made against him he found that
he did order the execution of a civilian
in Afghanistan and in the judge's words
on the balance of probabilities he did
kick a handcuffed prisoner off a cliff
and then ordered one of his fellow
members of that SAS regiment during that
deployment to shoot him dead today is a
day of Justice it's a day of justice for
those brave men of the SAS who stood up
and told the truth about who Ben Robert
Smith is a war criminal a bully and a
liar
Australia should be proud of although
he's been in the SAS they are the
majority in the SAS
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the findings by Justice Anthony basenko
today that Robert Smith participated in
the execution of Afghans confirms our
reports that the Victoria Cross
recipient breached the Geneva Convention
and is a critical step towards Justice
for the families of the murder victims
thank you
[Music]